here we have a fun system of equations  Santa placenta is equal to 32 sine  squared a frosty plus cosine squared of  Frosty is equal to Tree Santa minus tree  times Frosty is equal to 16. what is the  value of tree Plus Santa raised to the  power of Frosty  to work it out we'll substitute each  picture by a variable let tree be equal  to T Santa be equal to S and frosty be  equal to f  we'll substitute in  from the first equation we can solve  that s is equal to 16. from the second  equation we have that t is equal to 1.  substitute into the third equation then  we know 16 minus 1 times f is equal to  16. this means 1 times f is equal to 0  so f is equal to zero finally we  substitute into the last equation 16 to  the power of 0 is equal to one and thus  we have one plus one is equal to the  answer of 2.